La deuxième chose, c'était le pardon.
J'ai dû demander pardon aux gens que j'avais blessés.
Même si je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils me pardonnent,
il était important que je le fasse car c'était la bonne chose à faire.
Il fallait aussi que je pardonne à moi-même.
La troisième chose, c'était la rédemption.
Pour moi, la rédemption signifiait
retourner dans ma communauté,
travailler avec des jeunes à risque qui étaient sur la même voie,
ça signifiait aussi ne faire plus qu'un avec moi-même.
A travers l'expérience de mon incarcération,
une des choses que j'ai découvertes est :
la majorité des hommes et des femmes incarcérés peuvent se racheter,
et en fait,
90% des hommes et des femmes incarcérés
vont à un moment revenir dans leur communauté,
nous devons participer à la détermination
de quels types d'hommes et de femmes peuvent revenir dans leur communauté.
Mon souhait aujourd'hui,
c'est que nous adoptions
une approche plus empathique
de la façon dont nous traitons l'incarcération de masse,
que nous nous débarrassions de la mentalité
du « enfermons-les et jetons la clé »,
car il est prouvé que ça ne fonctionne pas.
Mon voyage est unique,
mais il n'est pas obligatoire d'en passer par là.
Tout le monde peut se transformer
si on crée un espace pour que ça soit possible.
Ce que je vous demande aujourd'hui,
c'est d'imaginer
un monde où les hommes et les femmes
ne soient otages de leur passé,
où les méfaits et les erreurs
ne vous définissent pas pour le restant de vos jours.
Je pense que collectivement, nous pouvons créer cette réalité.
J'espère que vous aussi.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)